okay here are our questions from the
overtime group senator King what do you
and Bernie Sanders
why do you unburned Sanders continued to
remain independence
despite caucusing with Democrats good
question because it gives me a chance to
work on both sides of issues I don't
think there's a necessarily anybody has
a monopoly on the truth and I can I can
work with one side or the other I work
with Republicans on some issues
Democrats on others but you have to
caucus with somebody because that's how
you get a committee assignment caucusing
doesn't mean you sign anything is
basically who you have lunch with on
Tuesdays right Oh interesting
okay uh Gavin why do you support raising
the minimum wage in California there's a
nice softball for yeah I mean you know
look we all know this economic growths
been a spectator sport for too many
people wages are flat salaries of that
and we need to step it up you know I'm
as you may know I've got 18 small
businesses so I understand this issue
yeah we have close to a thousand
employees so the impact of the minimum
wage I understand deeply from the other
perspective and I could tell you as a
former mayor of a city that had the
highest minimum wage in the United
States and I was intimating this earlier
the city has never done better
economically this notion that somehow
raising the minimum wage is going to
kill job growth and job creation it's
just simply untrue it's factually
incorrect
we need ass cut we need it we need to
get on the
we do think of that anything like it oh
no yes
wait shipping um no I just gonna say I
like one in San Francisco no what a
shock yeah sorry I'm sorry
go ahead no I had darling tell um no the
only thing I was gonna add there is you
know one of the things that I think is
so important when we think about
economic growth is if you don't build
middle-class prosperity you are not
gonna have sustainable economic growth
if people don't have money to do it
you're not gonna have you sit on the
growth and that's why anything you can
do to support the middle class and the
people who are struggling to join it is
gonna be good for the economy other
person okay do uh man do Republicans
have an alternative strategy to Obama in
Syria I think that they do unfortunately
I'm not sure those strategies are better
I think that the unfortunate thing for
the Republicans when it comes to Syria
is that their natural inclination is to
want to go the boots-on-the-ground route
or do something of that nature but
they've also had this tug of war within
their consciousness about it because
they've never really worked through the
lessons of the Bush era when it came to
that sort of issue I think the window
has actually passed the point where you
could achieve what a lot of Republicans
wanted to do in terms of getting rid of
Assad instead now you're at a point
where you're you are going to have to
form a coalition with other Muslims
Druze
Rand with Russia and and target and
target Isis using ill along those lines
as opposed to what they might have been
able to do but I always hear them say
he's weak and he's this and he's that
and then when it comes to time to put up
but what did you actually do differently
it's a lot of but this time around this
time around it's because none of them
really want to admit the fact that
they're going to have to cave to Putin's
priorities which leads to a situation in
in the Middle East where Russia is
viewed as a better patron than and more
reliable one when it comes to drawing
red lines than the
Andy what can we expect from the new
Real Housewives series and that is a far
more important question for a number of
reading I left off the beginning a
follow-up question Andy what can what
can we expect from the new Real
Housewives series in the DC suburbs yeah
that would tell me Oh Real Housewives of
Potomac that's a great I don't the
Salafis torpedo the Real Housewives of
DC if you remember the party gosh worse
years ago salute uh but we've got this
great group of women we weren't looking
to do a housewives again in that area
but we found these women in Potomac who
are very Potomac proud and they're all
about etiquette it reminds me of kind of
early days of the housewives it's great
are they housewives of politicians no
they're not it's not it's very
apolitical oh what a shame why don't you
do I know that would be great that would
be great but you can I'd love to get
Michele Bachmann on a real housewife
show I mean shoo I mean she's kind of
perfect and I bet you'd like to meet her
husband anyway actually actually
actually I got another one I bet he'd
like to meet me yes actually axe
that's much done
that's that's absolutely uh what do you
make of the Charlie Sheen thing you know
I mean I'm not gonna make any jokes cuz
I mean I've had my fun with Charlie
Wright but I also know him a little bit
and you know this is serious this is not
time for snarky comments right well it
was an interesting week because before
he came out and said I have HIV there
was a it felt like the 80s where there
was this HIV shame going around where
and then that it turned out that he was
coming out because he had been bribed uh
you know he didn't want to disclose the
information then live in black man I
need been blackmailed I'm sorry but on
the Today Show I found his uh his I
found it a little irresponsible that he
was on with this doctor who was saying
that the doctor was guiding him through
having unprotected sex with these
high-risk individuals and it just seemed
to me like he had an opportunity to kind
of say something or do something and he
kind of the message was very murky I
left feeling very confused I obviously
wish him great health and uh but it was
upsetting and then to find out that
there were what he claimed oh I've told
everyone that I've been with that you
know this is my status but then all
these women came out and said no that
he's never told me it just got very
messy very quickly but Tigers blood does
not prevent it it does cut wood what did
you think by the way I mean I'm assuming
you've known him for a long time we're
not like that well no I know I know I I
have had dinner with him so I got a gut
check to me no I mean I think it's I
mean first of all I think it's
interesting that when you think about
the heterosexual men who've gotten it
Magic Johnson right Charlie Sheen people
who have like [ __ ] every every quest
of Labre right Charlie Sheen was in
Heidi Fleiss as little black book 21
years ago he was only name that came out
of that book so right this has been
going on a long time yeah I mean and
people said to be all porn stars well
that's their living I don't know
jump at anytime we have porn stars have
to getcha markets and everything that
they do for a living they got to protect
the moneymaker good I mean I got like I
have some special knowledge of sin abuse
uh Christian what do you think of Justin
Trudeau's plan to lift visa requirements
for Mexicans coming to Canada uh well
Justin Trudeau is the Prime Minister of
Canada he's the leader of my party uh
he's my boss
so of course I think it's a very good
plan spoken like a true politic and I
get a good plan I mean you know Mexico
is a very important partner for Canada
understand you know having better
relations with Mexico is really
important to it and I've said this
before on the show but just to put
things in perspective I mean Europe has
to worry about people coming to their
society and trying to destroy it the
people who come from Mexico don't want
to destroy our society they want to join
it right and they make great food and
they enjoy sexy dancing all cultures are
not alike I'm sorry
okay what does the panel think of Bernie
Sanders statement that climate change is
linked to the threat of terrorism he's
right absolutely
the Syrian war started part partly
because there was a horrible drought
there that drove all the farmers into
the city there was nothing for them to
do cause what's gonna happen with
Bangladesh is underwater
yeah they're gonna be million well
that's the the other refugee crisis
right 630 plus million people live in a
coastline that are vulnerable to
sea-level rise but you know it's a good
point close to a million people were
displaced during that four-year epic
drought in Syria northern Syria and
Assad didn't react to it created
conditions that sparked the civil war
ultimately created the instability or
terrorists were able to take advantage
of that in vulnerabilities but it's
certainly an accelerant it's certainly
something that the Pentagon is
identified as quote-unquote a threat
multiplier and it's something that's not
unique to Syria as well you've seen it
in Nigeria you've seen it certainly as
part of the conversation around the Arab
Spring and food price increases it is a
serious and significant issue and that's
why again these Paris talks are critical
as it relates not just to climate but
also the broader conversation but not
every day you see Bernie Sanders and the
Joint Chiefs of Staff on the side page
on it yeah and and again California I
think was the state that got the country
better mileage standards wasn't it yeah
we hella fornia decided that we would
not accept cars that didn't have a
certain level and the it's too big a
market or Detroit not to make every car
though decades before the federal
government finally put themselves in a
position to adopt similar strategy look
we have a low carbon green growth
strategy we're committed to radically
changing the way we produce and consume
energy we're the only large-scale
cap-and-trade program in the United
States our economy deals with Ontario
Quebec and local partnerships and turn
the Western Hemisphere and so look
California is we're in the how business
we're not just isolating an ideal we
don't get the respect we deserve that's
the bottom line isn't it true because
the media is
the media's in New York
oh it's a greatest city in the world
that we don't get the respect we deserve
you [ __ ] yeah
you